these adventurous diners all belong to
the Explorers Club which hosts the
annual dinner at New York's Waldorf
Astoria Hotel past and present members
include the first men to reach the polls
the first to climb Everest and the first
man on the moon
they're a bold bunch of adventurers and
field scientists and tonight they'll
have to prove their courage all over
again
just having a small bit of a bear claw
and a little bit of eyeball I just had
the pork testicles that was cooked in
blood
each extraordinary dish was devised by
an equally remarkable man Jean burka is
the club's exotic food chairman he's a
biologist with a passion for sustainable
hunting wildlife preservation and
curious cuisine this has been going on
for well over a hundred years the club
is now 103 years of age a hundred and
third dinner
no one has dropped dead at explore stop
function but keep in mind these are
unusual foods and I think the Heimlich
maneuver might be a good thing to
practice
and I go to Kabul for each event takes
two years to plan exotic animals living
and dead frozen and fresh are purchased
from around the world eventually they
all arrive at genes farm in Somerset New
Jersey we have 60 plus items the insects
of course is some of the more popular we
have the like the cockroaches in the
tarantulas a live turtle free turtle
soup we have you know rattlesnake we
have some organ meats kidneys and we
have a duck tongue again this year
insure gene sources animals and animal
parts that we in the West rarely eat
often enough we don't even think of them
as food gene hopes to push tonight's
dinner guests outside their food comfort
zone
exotics today so most of us might be
having goose at Christmas dinner about
98% or any more of our protein sources
are in a few areas it's a valid point
we only eat a tiny fraction of the food
that's available the rest we consider
taboo we actually eat only what we pigs
cows goats sheep all right that's about
it we eat no amphibians no reptiles and
a very small number of the fish species
available and of course no insects which
are the most common species what do you
think if your mission here the testicles
of bull Raj gene aims to entice people
to try what millions of others safely
eat every day through choice or
necessity it also we might not go as as
a as a group today and say well I want
the eyeball you probably not for you but
when you don't have great hunting great
protein sources possibly the eye you
wouldn't want to waste tonight's menu
include a past Club favorite the
Madagascar hissing cockroach it's hard
to believe we could save or something
we'd normally step on people really have
enjoyed them it's an eye-catcher very
healthy again non fattening
like many insects the hated roach has
three times the protein ounce for ounce
of chicken and tastes like shrimp